hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're
getting you want to try to finish that
page that we started on Monday and
before we get started I just want to
take a minute maybe not even a minute to
explain what the stream is about because
there is a little bit of confusion that
came out in the comments section of
Monday's video so I think I've I've
gotten so used to streaming and we have
a lot of regulars that I've kind of
stopped explaining what the stream is
about him I do it occasionally but not
regularly so especially for everyone
who's new in this stream it's it's not
exactly a tutorial although I do my best
to explain things what the stream is all
about is just giving you a glimpse into
what I do as a front-end developer at a
university so I what I show you is
entirely unrehearsed it's what I need to
do for that day at my job so we jump in
we're in the middle of a project it's
just wherever I leave off at and we work
how I would normally work so that means
I won't start from scratch or take some
take you through step by step if we can
copy and paste from somewhere else to
save time we'll do that so if you want
some more explanation if I don't give a
good enough explanation you feel free to
ask in the live chat but you know
sometimes I I won't go step by step that
you you couldn't necessarily just follow
one stream and really be able to go and
do it on your own without maybe checking
out the code yourself and running
through it so if you're still interested
in watching after that then we're gonna
get started and I I really think there
are a lot of great pre-recorded
tutorials out there and that's part of
the reason why one
to do my streams like this I wanted to
do live and I want to do just how I
normally do things because that's I
that's what's unique about what I'm
doing I I really appreciate all the
tutorials but one thing that happened to
me when I was getting started is that it
led me to think that I wasn't quite as
good which I'm sure I wasn't as good as
those people but it's unrealistic and it
was unrealistic for me to base how good
I was on pre recorded edited tutorials
right so I just want to let everybody
see I'm a real developer right so and
basically I get paid to write code and
build things so I mess up all the time
I'm not perfect I misspell things I
caused bugs I fix bugs right so that's
the value of this stream now on top of
that it's really collaborative so you
all give me ideas and encode and we try
things and sometimes it doesn't work but
you know you all get to see that and go
through that with me so anyway I'm gonna
try my best to go through a shorter
explanation than I just did right now at
the beginning of every stream so that
way new people are watching especially
people maybe you just watch the
pre-recorded video and they just stick
around for the first minute you know
they won't be confused okay
where's my berries okay so this is what
I was working on just to bring you up to
date on the changes since Monday I end
up not streaming Tuesday or Wednesday
because I was working from home last
time I tried to see him from home the
quality was was bad so I had to do some
boring stuff anyway that wouldn't have
made for good stream so I figured I'll
just wait and I'll stream from the
office today so here's what I've done my
boss went through this menu so let me
show you visually what this looks like I
don't need this right now I don't need
this right now
don't sit okay so we have this menu oops
that's not it
there we go all right so we have this
menu here and so all the information for
this menu and all the dropdowns and
everything are contained in in this file
this drawer menu j/s right and we can
see it's just a collection of constants
that we export and each constant is an
array so it's an array of objects so we
can loop through all those objects you
know use map filter you know whatever
you want on these objects now each one
of these constants corresponds to a
section in the menu right so my boss
went through all those and significantly
decreased the number of items in there
and even changed some items so some
items are completely different they
weren't in there before so what I've
done is I've gone through and I made a
copy of the original menu just in case
my boss changes his mind or we needed to
add things back in so made a copy of it
and that's drum and you long
Jaso you'll notice an extra file there
in the data folder if you want to see
the code for yourself the link is in the
description so please feel free to check
that out use it for whatever you want to
for whatever you want to use it for so
this is the the new menu stuff and what
I've done is at least got the text in
there so some of these items here at the
bottom don't have the correct links yet
I need to fill that out but at least we
can see and my boss can see what the new
menu looks like and yeah much much
shorter so if you can believe it it's
much shorter so that's what I've been
working on mostly I've done a lot of
other stuff with things on the WordPress
side of side of it
cleaning up data and generally getting
routes to work with that server j/s file
so that's what's new but today we're
gonna go back to actually yeah I don't
want to close that out because I'm gonna
go back to this one I'm done so let's
find those pages we were working on so
we were working on this admissions j/s
and you can see we for right now we're
just kind of really sloppily hard coding
a lot of stuff just to see how it looks
on the page before we break it out into
components so Phoenix you're on time
Phoenix was worried about in the
intellect only on time I'm just kind of
explaining what I've done the last few
days in this project so let's let's do a
few things one I'm gonna start up and
grukk so and rock will allow you all to
run what I'm running locally on your
computer in your browser and you'll be
able to inspect it my dev tools just
like you were running it locally okay so
I just pasted that link into the live
chat so if you click it and it doesn't
take you the right place then try to
copy and paste
that occasionally there's an issue in
with links in the chat window all right
so that's ready you don't have to be on
the same page with me either you can
click around try things out if you see
something really crazy happening let me
know about it
you can let me know in the stream or
even better create an issue on github
with a screenshot or something so we
have that ready and we need to actually
go to that page as we can see what we're
doing so I think it's admissions great
so here's what we have so far we have
this here a section which will most
likely have a different image in the
background this is the same image we're
using on the home page we cut down the
size of the hero section just to see how
it looks we may or may not change the
size and we'll probably change this text
these are just some kind of placeholders
so these will end up being like
testimonials from from former students
and it'll be about the same structure
but we do want to try to keep these all
the same height so that's one thing that
will change and then we have this
section here that I had thought maybe we
could list out all the majors that we
offer if we break out in categories and
it would look ok so what we've done is
just very basically laid it out just to
get some visual like is this even doable
will this look terrible or not so I
think what we can do for this section is
actually make this a component so that
we can start to put in some data we can
we could actually pull in we may be able
to pull in a list of all the majors
I don't know we probably will have to
make that list though because I don't
think it exists right now in in a format
in WordPress that we can work with yeah
so well I'll have to think about that
but that's one thing we may get to today
and then we need all this is just kind
of run over from what we copy and pasted
before so this is all gonna change we
just left it around for easy copy and
paste all right but let's let's get rid
of some of this then because now we've
gotten down to the point where I think
we should start changing that up okay
and I see some some action there in the
live chat so I have this timer that I'm
about to start when this 25 minutes is
up I'm gonna go back to the live chat
and I'm gonna answer all your questions
I'm gonna read your comments and then
we'll go back to code and then we'll
take a break so I'll try to go back and
forth so if you did ask something just
hold on I will get to it if you can't
stick around for me to answer it you can
always watch the recording later on and
I'll try to answer it you know when I
get time later on in the stream let's
see I did see one question is emselves
how long do these streams last at least
an hour usually sometimes more okay all
right yeah so let's get rid of I just
want to get rid of all this stuff and
just have it have it clear cuz this
components huge and I just don't really
want to scroll around any more with it
so I'm gonna start here I guess at this
masonry yeah it was started at this
masonry component
it did make it easier to leave it all in
because now that we did that we're gonna
have to take some of this stuff up or
else we're gonna get errors there we go
okay we may end up adding some of that
stuff back in alright there we are okay
and I did have let me bring up my my
really rudimentary sketch so that we all
can see it again I need to refresh my
memory on what I sketched out for how
this page is gonna look okay
so let's
okay
okay
let's try to zoom in here we are okay so
we have basically these sections plus
our testimonials that I kind of added in
after the fact we don't need the online
this was a sketch for a slightly
different page but it's similar enough
that we just kind of reusing this sketch
so I guess what we could do now is maybe
include how to apply section here I
think if we if we put in a how to apply
section and maybe leave in a section for
let's get rid of these so let's let's
leave
maybe this section just as an example of
you know what what could be done maybe
I'll ask my boss to fill in some content
there and then we'll just we'll add in a
section like we see here where we can
have how to apply and we'll just throw
kind of this stuff in there then we can
I can let my boss see it I'll send him a
link
he can think up all right what content
are we gonna put there and then we can
go back to it and maybe adjust it so
it's funny my boss asked me about it was
a different page but it's the same
concept he asked me earlier he said what
what's his page gonna look like I want
to know what it's gonna look like before
I think about what content is gonna have
and I said well I was waiting to see
what content we're gonna have before I
figure out what its gonna look like so
we have a back and forth with that the
design is very fluid alright let's get
to it
so let's take out yeah
it'll be nice when we break this out
into a component way that's scrolling
let's break out our vision and we're
just going to keep this tech section and
this nib is just kind of hanging out
here not doing anything huh I must have
accidentally oops you know what maybe I
think my editor automatically did that
since there was no content in it so that
makes sense now Dave so within this div
let's just let's grab what we did here
and then just modify it I think it'll be
a lot easier to do it like that so let's
take this entire grid container
component and put it in here inside of
this content container which actually we
can we can just remove this div because
we already added the content container
class on to this grid item so that's
nice just get rid of that and what we've
done here we can remove a bit so if you
remember on Monday we added in some
empty grids so that we could get this
kind of gap here so we'll take those out
I don't need those anymore
what did I grab did I grab too much
is it at
there it is okay so we'll take those out
and we only need three sections so let's
remove the rest yeah we are okay so I
already like these sections how they're
set up so on extra small screen it'll
take up 12 out of 12 columns across and
on a small screen and up it will take up
4 out of 12 columns so that means we can
have three items side by side and I do
want to remove all of this stuff so to
get rid of that and then inside of there
for now let's just create let's just
create a header tag for now so we'll
make these H threes and see how that
looks
and I'm just gonna add a text
placeholder right there whoops
three can't type there we are
okay so this will end up being our steps
to apply where why would it I have there
there we go application transcripts and
letters of recommendation okay
an application transcripts
that is a recommendation all right let's
see how that looks
all right obviously pretty plain let's
it's add a little styling here we could
probably use some styling here as well
so let's add some styling to this grid
container yeah
so we have our Styles here and you know
what I'm gonna we had decided a while
back that we were gonna move our Styles
to the bottom or we were at least going
to try that
the reason being we can then if we move
our styles to the bottom when
immediately when when someone comes
especially someone new opens this this
file they can immediately see what this
components all about instead of seeing a
long list of styles so I think it's just
a nicer experience if you're new to the
component so if we just move them down
here they'll work in same same way they
normally work but now they're not kind
of blocking the view of the of the
component especially when we get a lot
of styles like we do here I think it
just it looks a lot nicer to put them at
the bottom okay so content container
right now we we're giving it a top and
bottom margin of zero but I think I want
to increase that and give it just a
little margin so let's just try 16
pixels for now
it's one of little separation so we just
have a little bit up probably want to go
bigger than that
that seems let's let's double it let's
try 32 pixels okay
a little better a little better
some things I'm noticing here that
definitely need to change this h3 stuff
is just it's not the right font and it's
way too small
I don't know what's going on there I I
don't understand why it's not the right
font I thought we were automatically
making everything use Roboto so let's
check that out
what we are bringing in some CSS maybe
maybe not
hmm
I wonder if we didn't bring in any CSS
files for this it looks like we didn't
okay
okay
I'm just wondering if we can import an
existing CSS file without messing up the
Styles too much I'm gonna try it so
let's check out our CSS files don't want
to do it like this I I don't think I
want to do it like this but we may have
to because we are eventually we are
gonna be bringing in my concern is this
when we bring in content from WordPress
sometimes we want that content to be
styled like there could potentially be
HTML tags that we're bringing in we
can't directly style them like we're
doing here right because we we won't
even see those components we can't put a
class on them so if we have this
external stylesheet that could select
things like an h3 that's inside of you
know a div and it's all living in
WordPress and not here that that's why
we're using external style sheets as
well as we develop our data more in
WordPress we should need to rely less
and less on them but I don't think we're
ever going to be able to completely get
rid of them so if you want to learn more
about that maybe check out some of the
previous streams as to why we're doing
some things that maybe we wouldn't
normally do if this was just straight-up
react and we had total control over all
the the data coming in so let's find our
Styles here
I believe our page CSS and let's let's
move this over here so we can see both
let me know if if this font is too small
as well
so what I'm looking for okay Maine has
the font family of Roboto do we even
have Maine here I don't think we do
let's check out check out another page
where we're probably using this all
right hjs
you know maybe we we do have Maine
happening somewhere yep okay all right I
see so are kind of our wrapper around
everything does have this main tag
if if we put a link to our page CSS here
and have it apply everywhere that may be
the best way to go and then we'll try
our best to make sure that this file
stays really small
I'm here we can get rid of some of these
right now
could definitely get rid of CV link
okay
all right yelling I'm thinking is maybe
material I already has some way to do
this and I just don't know so I'm gonna
check this it's a few s theme there we
are okay so I'm just checking to see
where we're importing our theme from so
we do have this fu s theme and the lib
folder let's check that out
okay so for now it's gonna be a lot
easier for me to just do normal CSS
it'll probably be a lot easier if y'all
to understand as well but there is a way
we could probably style a lot of this
through here and this may end up being
the best way to do it
but for now since we kind of need to
mess around with the Styles a lot and
get them right I'm just gonna go with
get old CSS and what we're gonna do is
whoops some of this over here and then
open up that page dot J s this is kind
of our default and where we we're gonna
take this we're gonna take it out of
here and we're gonna link it here yeah
so we're gonna like to here instead what
we're gonna have to do is really be
careful though and make sure that this
isn't causing conflicts you know in our
in our other pages so you'll see how it
is we'll also need to make sure we
remove this this link from all the files
which actually can we do that let's see
if we can do that right now
mmm-hmm and I won't let us search for
that whole thing
all right cool thought it was worth a
shot so not right now but at some point
someone I have to go through and remove
all these so it'll try end up being me
but some of these files will have that
same link we don't want to load it twice
right but now we're gonna be loading it
globally so let's see if any changes
have happened oh yeah admissions let's
see what's happening uh okay the font is
definitely different right our font is
Roboto let's check out everything else
okay everything else looks fine it looks
the same I don't know if any of you
notice any other differences but that
this looks good to me
all right great so that takes care of
that and that now gives us a way to add
styles globally
all right so let's get to work on this
and this I wonder if there's icons that
we could use if anybody thinks of any
material icons so icons that normally go
with material design that would work for
these three things application
transcript and letters of recommendation
let me know in the chat because that
might be a good place to use icons so I
mean obviously if we had a letter icon
that would probably work there
transcripts I don't know maybe maybe
something like a page you know I don't
know what to do for application but
maybe you have some icons and then of
course we're gonna add in links
and I kind of think that this section
might be better off in a different
different place
I'll leave it for now see you my boss
Thanks let's grab these and fix these
right because that's that needs to be
done we need to break these out new
component and this is I really want to
see the actual text here
all right so whenever we make a new
component I think the best way to do it
is just copy the most similar component
that we already have and try to use that
so let's close out some of these things
we'll leave this up because we're like
we might change this
and all right we have a sample schedule
component here let's just grab this and
we use this as the basis for new
components where we go in our components
folder here and I'll just click in there
and make this list which we call this
I'm gonna call it header list dodge is
because we are gonna have a header on
our list so make sense 50 header list
all right so let's paste this in here
and this is going to be may end up being
useful because we already have some some
mock data here so we may be able to just
use some of this to see if we can get
this to work for now
you'll see how it goes probably have to
copy and paste it out so we can keep so
we can keep and we need to get rid of
for now let's get rid of pretty much
everything yeah we get rid of everything
and just start fresh and this is what
we're gonna grab you might think like
what's the point if you just deleted
everything but like this stuff this
stuff saves us from having to type it
out again we're gonna name this after
our component which is header header
list and I messed up when I named this
because normally we name components with
capitals starting with a capital letter
okay all right so it's complaining here
about indentation it is complaining here
about the way we're styling this which
makes sense let's get rid of our tabs
and let's get rid of our grid
let's get rid of this UUID for now we
can always bring it back if we need it
and we're gonna keep some of this list
styling and apply them here but we can
also move in our styles from here which
we move down here so what we need to
bring in then is our our list our list
header major list item
there we are all down here oops yeah
so we can I'm gonna keep these in here
right now do I need to let's just take a
mom because eventually we're not we're
not gonna need these everything will be
in this this other component so let's
pull these put these in here for now you
may be able to remove some of this as
well because some of these were for
slightly different use although it's a
list with a header again yeah see it's
oh we already had it oh okay I didn't
realize we had just repeated those okay
well and we can get rid of this we you
know what we may be able to use the same
component for our sample schedule and in
here that would be nice trying to make
components as reusable as possible is
always good okay let's set the
five-minute time Rick this timer just
went out and I'm gonna go talk to the
live chat try to answer as many
questions as I can in five minutes
Harvin asked if this is related python
no this is JavaScript is em asked what
we're using for back-end nodejs although
we do have content management coming
from WordPress so we have done a little
PHP as well misssara says did you use
sequel eyes or have you taken data from
WordPress using graph QL we're using
graph QL and also the WordPress REST API
in some places
Blake's here Michael's here hey how's it
going
as M says do you use some third-party
software to generate your objects during
development no I do not but that
probably wouldn't be a bad idea
Oh Sean says is this new livestream
because I'm having this feeling that it
has been aired before I don't know I
don't know maybe maybe I definitely
repeat myself a lot so me but I'm really
here you'll need to hold up the date on
my phone I will prove it look at this
July 19th I guess it's not really
focusing let's see
michael says michael le mu says could
you post the video after live chat yes
the all the all the videos from the
streams are posted pretty much
immediately after the stream is over it
may take a minute or so to process but
they are available actually if you want
to watch the video recording I recommend
watching it on like two times speed I
think it's it goes a lot faster you can
still understand what I'm saying
and it makes me look really good because
I solve problems in half the time and I
tight fast so that's how I watch me if I
watch the stream
Oh Sean says Jessi worked on a
similar-looking site months before yep
it's still the same site still working
on it
definitely the development for this site
has gone on significantly longer than I
had planned originally Sahil says I got
my first job last week free code camp
was really helpful Thanks well you're
you're well on behalf of free code camp
you're welcome I don't know how helpful
I was individually maybe not at all but
I really excited for you about your job
please you know if you can you know come
back to the stream and let us know like
how your jobs go on it will cool stuff
you're working on if you can
Phoenix says hey Jesse our site has no
favicon any plans on adding it yeah for
sure
every time I notice it I I'm doing
something else so yeah I would
definitely need that in there I thought
I added one somewhere
I just never linked it up so I think the
file exists somewhere in all of this
stuff
as M says do you ever use alternative
styling solutions when working with
material you I like using styled
components or some elements that don't
need to reference the thing I haven't
used styled components with material UI
I've used them on on other projects but
we we generally try to try out a variety
of of things so I'm open to trying a lot
of different things tell you the truth
last time you solid components it was a
little weird for me I don't want to make
a judgment about style components until
I've used them more and can get used to
them but my first impression was I was a
little thrown off I'm I could understand
what's going on but it was it would seem
weird to me the way everything was
working so like I said I don't want to
make a quick judgment unless I really
give it a shot I feel like I haven't
given it a fair chance yet so I'd like
to work with them on a different project
though I don't really want to try we're
so close to the end here I don't want to
start it now but maybe on a future
project we can we can use it on mpg says
sometimes a bit confuses me to customize
some to your UI elements sometimes not
working when we just controlled it by
with style yet their material I it's it
is a little tricky sometimes and things
change with depending on what version
you're using so overall I think it does
help but definitely had to modify things
Michael says you watch your own streams
I'm sure I could not I'm not sure I
could watch myself yeah it took a while
to get used to but mainly I watched my
own streams whenever I need to remember
how I did something and then they're
really helpful because I can a lot of
times when I'm done with the project I
don't go back and revisit it for a while
and I forget things that I did and
during the project I just remember
things you know because you're doing it
every day but after a month or so you
forget so I need I go back in i rewatch
how i did it it saves me a lot of time
okay let's my timer went off so let me
start another session will do at least
one more Pomodoro session and and then
maybe QA we'll see how this it's still
kind of early so I might get in three
Pomodoro sessions but we'll see how that
is the really really long streams like
the two-hour long shrimps take a lot out
of me so we'll see I don't know if I if
I'm down for that rate right now
where was that oh I just brought the
styles over okay so we brought these
styles over and now we need to let's
let's pull some of this over actually
because this already has the yeah this
already has things in here
okay yeah this is good we'll bring this
in
yeah
okay that's gonna save us some time so
what we need to do though it's it's
actually it's gonna be a little tricky
to try to use this component in both
cases because of the way I set up this
data well this I mean this is how it was
coming out of WordPress so for now I'm
gonna make this work for the admissions
page and then maybe sometime later I'll
try to make it work on you know for the
sample schedule since this sample
schedule is already working as intended
I'm not gonna mess with it right now but
that's like I think a potentially good
refactor that'll save a few lines okay
so what we want to do we're not worried
about the year
the hearts value
okay we don't need this at all this
handle change or the state value we also
don't need you don't need this okay and
we're gonna have our styles of fine of
course let's change this up alright so
we're gonna get the data in and we will
have a header and then course they're
not courses majors but let's try to make
it as generic as possible so we can
definitely say here that this is going
to be the header and so the text for
this let's let's call this data dot
header and then let's let's call this
let's go data items map and then instead
of course we'll call this item
okay I for our key I think we can just
use item you know what let's see let's
just use this will bring this back this
is a little bit safer to use so in in
react when your your mapping over
something and adding you know multiple
components to the page you need to have
a unique key so sometimes you can just
grab some of the data you're bringing in
as long as it's unique but in this case
it's some cases it's possible that what
you pull in may not be unique and in
that case we're going to use this this
UUID to just give us unique values okay
so it's just gonna make random numbers
and put it in there so let's use that
and then we don't have to worry about it
I don't think it'll be a problem I think
every one of these will be unique but
just in case we're gonna use that okay
so the data this data is actually gonna
live for now over here in admissions
so let's yeah let's put it down here so
what we need for our data let's just
call this we call it data let's give it
a little better name here maybe majors
yeah we'll call it majors oops
and majors is going to be an array of
objects so yeah it's gonna be array of
objects each object is going to have a
header and so let's just say for now
business so you want business and then
it's gonna have
Magers
I'm just gonna call this majors array
because I don't want to get this
confused so majors and then within here
we're also gonna have name and we can
have a major said the best way to do it
not really right we don't need it to be
like that do we
let me think about that might be like
more complicated than we even need it to
be right now so I'm thinking like when
we go to loop through this could we we
just leave it as an array right you know
could I just say accounting economics
[Music]
I'll go through and put some real ones
in here but all right so then over here
when we pull this in as data we would
say data this entire thing is gonna have
to be okay so when data comes in it'll
come in as just one one section right so
it'll be data dot header and that'll
give us business okay so that makes
sense then we'll go down here data dot
items so maybe we should put items here
yeah let's do that and then we can
change this back to just say majors all
right so that would have change that to
items so we can keep it here so major
start items equals mmm
actually you know what we can make this
I mean I've been thinking in my head a
lot not talking a lot so let me let me
tell you what I've been thinking okay so
if we pull in the data like this it's
it's gonna be a little bit difficult
right because for a data source this
name could be different for you know a
variety of different things we're going
for so that makes this kind of difficult
you know to put in here but what if when
we actually pass this data as props we
pass it as two different props so the
first prop is the header the second prop
will be the items and then it doesn't
matter what this is actually called
because we'll pass it in as just an
array so when we pass it in then we'll
have it it'll just say items
all right so items dot map okay we'll
just give us item right and so it's a
literally it would just be the value of
of item okay so I think that's that's
better right
that seems better to me let me know what
y'all think let me know if I'm even
making sense at all right now let's see
how we broke out props here wow that's a
lot of props
I just like to copy and paste as much as
possible I always have to look at other
components to remember where to put
things like within what set of
parentheses and things do it and that
brackets do I need to put this so since
that works for this one I'm guessing
it'll work over here so let's let's
break out some of the props we know
we're gonna have to put in here so we're
destructuring and then that way we won't
have to keep typing this props but I
also really like doing this because as
soon as you go to a component you know
automatically what props are being
passed in you don't have to search
through through this component okay so
we're gonna have the header as a prop
right and we'll have the items as a prop
okay so now you see the little squiggly
lines disappeared from here we no longer
need data right because header is just
gonna come through as a string right so
we can just put header in there all
right cool that might be it so we need
anything else for now I don't I don't
think we do let's get rid of course data
as well because we don't need that
anymore
that was shortened up this component
significantly great okay
all right not bad a nice small component
great okay so let's let's just copy and
paste this a few times just to give us
some sample data and we'll just change
this up I don't even know let's just do
two three I don't want to take time to
find actual courses right now just put
that in there so we know which is which
so now cost majors and let's go up here
and we're going to add let's see this is
gonna be kind of tricky since we have
those spacers right hmm
this is gonna be difficult what was I
thinking
all right this can still work it's just
gonna be slightly more complicated than
I wanted it to be
all right well first things first let's
just give this a shot
all right
okay so we're gonna say we're gonna add
our curly brackets which takes us into
JavaScript right so now we can write
JavaScript inside these curly brackets
we're gonna say major
it wasn't majors yeah majors dot map
right we can map over it because majors
is an array and we're gonna say we call
this list yeah
list sounds good so let's say list you
would do an arrow function here and then
let's pull this in right so we're gonna
loop over this and we should be able to
say we probably need a key here since
this is we're looping over this so the
key here could be list dot header right
that should be unique and then now
inside of here we can do when we call
this one header list header list and we
need to pass it the props of header
header is going to equal list dot header
and items is gonna equal list dot items
and we need to bring in header list
right because we didn't actually import
it and what's this
import major from major
that's weird all right but we're not
using it so let's take it out
so let's import we're gonna import
header header list from and then we're
gonna tell it where this lives it lives
in the components folder and it's called
oh it already did it no I forgot it okay
so we had a question a few streams ago
about how I should get some plug-in to
like automatically add these and
evidently I do have it for whatever
reason it just didn't work at that
particular time but I guess I have it
cuz it added editor list for me
wonderful
so this squiggly line is probably just
indentation you have indentation okay so
let's check this I think this should
work yep should we see what we have
classes is not defined
did I leave classes in here
where's classes not the fun header list
44 that's that's really weird
maybe I just didn't save it from the
last time yep that's it I didn't save it
all right let's see what we have okay
cool so write this this is now rendered
these out awesome now here's the trick
here's the tricky part
we need we need these two to render but
we need this spacing here or at least I
want that spacing
so there's there's a couple ways we
could do this that I'm thinking right
so I guess there's two thing two ways
I'm thinking about doing this one way is
we have two times that we map through
the first time we map through and we get
the index and we only get the first
three items and then on our other map
it's for that index row and we only get
two items and we map through inside of
here like you know inside of this empty
grid component right and one yeah so
basically right here where we have these
which we can definitely remove these for
now all right and that's definitely a
possibility the other thing that we
could do is have basically go through
each grid item so we would leave we
wouldn't map over this the grid itself
so where we have this majors map so
where we have this grid here let me make
this a little bit easier to read
that was gonna automatically format this
for me I guess it's not one sir
why is it not going soon
all right anyway
you potentially we could say we could do
a filter and just say if the header like
the name of the header equals this then
render that now that I think about it
two Maps is better than five right there
we go I was waiting for it to do that
okay yeah so let's let's add in some
some more data here still just some test
data to do we get this worked out
all right so now we have enough data
where let's see it rendered all these
out right but that's not that's not what
we want it's not what we want it to look
like
so we'll do now is say that list and
then we want I as well
let's put these in parentheses so what
this I should be then is the index right
of this this map so our index like zero
one two right so we're gonna do this
index and then what we're gonna say is
we're gonna have to make some some
brackets right because we need to do
some JavaScript the parens the
parentheses
they auto return so we don't want to
return just yet what we want to say is
if I is less than three and Oh actually
can we do this as less than three wonder
if we can
oops
it's
that's not gonna work shoot okay
this is to say if I is less than isn't
3c this will work
then whatever turn grade what am I doing
wrong
Oh
yeah there we go
what I do here I don't need that huh
right in our system
now I do need this one I need one two
three baby
and then I need another one too many
going on here alright this is double
check I need this outer bracket the
outer part needs to be a bracket okay so
the outer bracket is here then I need
parenthesis then I need a bracket right
to cover this one then I need another
bracket to cover this one then I need
for rent for that this looks terrible
what am i doing
all right let's see if it works mmm nope
what did I do if I is greater than
whoops less than there we are
Thank You Kenny that actually works all
right cool so that works now we just
copy this paste it here and just say if
I is greater than or equal to three
there we go cool all right so that works
it's I kind of wish I wouldn't have to
do like the exact same maps twice I mean
maybe we could if it were more than
twice I think about maybe like just
extracting this part out I don't want to
put the grid in the component because it
would be not as reusable right so this
is it for now but that works so
basically this works and we we cut down
a lot right remember yet all this
hard-coded stuff and now if we could get
data like this in this format from
wordpress we don't have to mess with
changing this list someone who is in
charge of that area could just edit that
content so we add a major they can edit
themselves so if you take one away
whatever they can handle that and then I
don't have to manually go back so that's
that's always a good thing and let's see
okay
so that's my timer but I mean we
successfully extracted this out into its
own component potentially could reuse
this as well which is nice and you know
we've we've got it to where we're
displaying it here so definitely not
it's not finished right we're missing
lots of content but this may be enough
to show
boss and say okay given this layout what
do you want in these areas right do you
you know how do you want to arrange it
so yeah generally I tried not to mess
around with the like the content of like
what's the what's the text gonna be and
things like that I try not to mess with
that too much I'd rather just handle
kind of the code behind that okay well
that is my timer so I think now now is
actually it was good timing that that
went off so I'm not gonna do another
Pomodoro session I'm just gonna end with
with that with the successful completion
of a a new component so always it
especially for those of you who are new
always remember you know we we do things
here we get them done we get them
working fully understanding that we
could always refactor we could always
make improvements right so if this was a
tutorial and I was trying to teach you
like this is the absolute best way to do
it yeah we would do that but it's not
it's a real project and we have to say
okay will it be the benefit of me
refactoring is that benefit great enough
to take the time to do it you know given
our deadlines so unfortunately the
answer to that question most of the time
is no it doesn't really make sense if I
can remove four lines of code from this
component like nobody's gonna care
really you know even developers who look
at this later on aren't gonna freak
about four lines I mean unless I don't
know maybe they're really sensitive
about that so that's kind of what we're
weighing so I would pretty much
everything I do I'd always love to have
more time to make it better right but we
can't always do that so anyway just
wanted to give that disclaimer in case
some of you're probably thinking like
this dude what is this dude doing I
would never do it like that
which is totally legit or or some of you
may be thinking oh okay that's exactly
how you should do it no that's just how
we are doing it so it works for what we
needed to work for right now okay so
right now we don't need it to be perfect
or even optimal right okay
let's commit this so let's check our
status see what we've changed like
immune admission for this okay so we've
actually done a lot so we're gonna do
multiple commits here all right so yeah
I'm gonna do this because I don't think
I've really done multiple commits on the
stream I usually just just like add
everything so if you've done a lot and
then you want to break it out in
different commits you can do a get add
and then just add a particular file so
let's add pages dot page file and let's
also we just put a space we could add
another one let's add our Pages document
dot a s file and did we change our page
dot CSS I don't think we changed it what
did we change
interesting I don't remember changing
anything but I guess we'll just add that
as well
oops static styles page dot CSS okay so
those ones are all going to have to do
to us moving that page dot CSS up to be
global styles so now we're gonna do our
yarn CM so yarn cm for us here is a just
a little helper to help us write nice
commit messages so if you don't have
that installed to imagine most people
don't then you can just do git commit
and do M - a - M and then you can put
your commit message right so we'll just
say it's a new features so say make page
dot CSS a global local CSS file okay
as far as I know there are no breaking
changes or conflicts with styles so what
should happen and so there shouldn't be
conflicts is anything that's paid
specific would be loaded below so it
shouldn't it should override right the
cascading part of cascading style sheets
CSS should take effect and so it's we
should be able to still keep the styles
the thing that would be weird is you
know if Paige was never loaded and
there's something that we don't have a
ride so we'll just have to keep an eye
out for stuff like that okay great so
that's one commit out of the way let's
do a git status just to make sure yep
see now that those things are no longer
there to be added now we can just add
everything so we'll do a git add and
then just put a space and a dot a period
and that adds everything and we'll do
our yarn CM again and new feature
creates header list component no great
thing changes you know it doesn't affect
any issues so this will run through all
stuff and once it's ready then we'll do
a git push and everything we've done
today will be available on the git repo
our github repo link is in the
description you get push
awesome okay always recommend ending
your day with a get push you should
probably push frequently and beginning
your day where they get pull keep
yourself up to date and then keep the
repository up-to-date too if you have a
lot of people working on the project you
may want to push and pull multiple times
throughout the day maybe if you're doing
a Pomodoro's cycle like maybe at the
beginning and end of every you know
Pomodoro session try to push your pool
you know whatever you said but it's it's
a good practice to do and you can avoid
some weird merge conflicts okay I'm
gonna go back to the live chat and
answer any remaining questions that I
didn't get to last time if you have
questions please put them in the chat
I'm happy to answer questions about
anything especially if it's code related
it doesn't have to be necessarily
related to this particular project
though I see julio said hi hey how's it
going
okay so on mpg says based on your
experiences which one would you
recommend between bootstrap materialized
semantics or other okay so it definitely
depends if we're talking just a regular
JavaScript site without react bootstrap
is really nice if you want that material
design style I would go with
materialized CSS now if we're talking
about a react site I actually like
material you why I know there I there
are people that I definitely respect as
programmers that have a hard time with
it but I like it I've gotten used to it
I kinda I like the style I know my way
around the documentation so for now I'm
you know I'm happy with it
there are other options but that would
be my preference you know I have the
most experience with that so I don't
know that I'm the best person to make a
recommendation since I haven't used a
lot of different react UI frameworks in
terms of regular JavaScript ones I have
used bootstrap and I have used material
as CSS I think they're both good and the
main difference would be your preference
on style because they definitely have
different styles
Nikki says every time he says let's I
here go in my head
Phoenix says that's too much pub G bro
okay so I I haven't never played pub G
or watching you stream so that's that's
going over my head I'm assuming that
that's they say that in in pub G
Michaels Michael criolla says speaking
and watching your old streams do you
keep notes on what you do each stream so
you can jump back quickly if you need to
remind yourself I don't keep notes
usually I can kind of remember when I
did something and then based on the
titles I can figure out where I was at
but hmm so I threw the yarn it wouldn't
be a bad idea to after I do the streams
go back and change the titles and
descriptions based on what we actually
got done because I make the titles and
descriptions beforehand and it doesn't
always end up the way I think it's going
to end up so that's just kind of a time
thing like when I'm done with the stream
I'm tired usually they have something
else going on right after so I don't
have a lot of time to edit and then I
never go back to it
I need to get an intern right that's
what I need to get like a YouTube
marketing intern or something and have
them edit all my stuff we'll see maybe
I'll talk to the the marketing
department here at the University and
see if we can do that
on MPG sis usually for working with
projects like this how much time or how
long does it take to finish it for you
this suspense really long
I mean most of the reason why this is
taking so long is because of the data if
I were building this as a brand new site
and I didn't have to pull over all kind
of data it would have been done a while
ago right I spent a long long time
bringing over data you know editing the
data trying to work with it so that's
what's taking a long time so the stream
is kind of misleading like the length of
it that has been going on because when
I'm not streaming most of what I do does
not involve react at all or coding it
out most of it involves either migrating
data or editing that data so it's more
like content management which kind of
things I don't really enjoy doing that
it's pretty boring but so I guess your
question it's hard to answer the
question but I mean I think what we've
been working for this fraud
on this project for like six months I
mean I think we definitely could have
been half the time if this was a new
project where we didn't we didn't have
all these restrictions and have to do
all these workarounds based on what what
data we had and things like that
let's see Michael creo says it depends
on the structure of the data you could
do it as theta zero one okay so that
must have been when I was figuring out
what to what to do
Michael creo says which page already has
a list of majors we do have it should be
there we go academics ug majors has this
list of majors so I mean I guess we
could pull out majors here from this
list the problem is though like this
list doesn't break them up into
categories but I may be able to if I can
decide on categories well actually I'll
do see if my boss can decide on
categories and then figure out what
categories they could be in and then
have my student workers enter that data
in in in a format that would be better
maybe I could maybe I could work
let's see which pages Daniel says hola
saludos Adeste Mexico so I know what all
that is hey Daniel how's it going
cannabis places why do you like this and
then there's an expletive in there so
[Music]
Nicky says bracket para colorizer i know
i keeps getting recommended to me a lot
okay cannabis says this is insane
spaghetti code yeah I mean a lot of it
is so I mean it's kind of like I said
earlier like at this point in it like
it's pretty rough when we start to write
it you know eventually as we keep going
over it you know it gets refactored but
you know the thing is you know we get it
to a point where it works and you know
we try to get the components as small as
possible so yeah of course I mean I
don't know if cannabis place is still
around it seems like they were not happy
with the stream I definitely welcome
anybody to come a refactor stuff and
usually if somebody has a good refactor
and a nice pattern for how to do
components I stick with it you know
throughout the rest of the stream so the
way we do things now is is really a it's
a development of all your contributions
right so little by little we improve and
change the way we do things and that
just kind of keeps building right so
believe it or not this code is way
better than you know when I first
started streaming a year actually has
been longer than a year ago now so
definitely I'm under no illusions of
thinking my code is
perfect I can definitely improve so and
I definitely appreciate all your
suggestions on you know how to improve
so Canada displays if you're still
around right i i definitely welcome your
your criticism of my my code as being
spaghetti code but what would be like
more helpful to everybody me and
everybody watching is what specific
things could we do to make it like what
parts of it are the worst and what could
we do to fix that right and that's
generally like what this stream is kind
of about is we all help each other and
we get better so anyway so not sure if
you're still here you're not commenting
anymore but definitely would welcome a
pool request was for just an open an
issue on get up with some suggestions
and if we can we'll definitely implement
the suggestions
let's see michael Creole says I know I'm
a broken record but you're overthinking
this perfect is the enemy of good yeah
you're right i what i hope doesn't i
hope that the idea doesn't just get
thrown out completely since we spent i
don't know what like 20 minutes on it 25
Julio says I recommend bracket pair
colorizer to handle brackets frets these
curly braces easily you know what let me
get that now because people been
suggesting it to me it seems like for
months and I just never took the time to
do it so if I do it now it'll get done C
bracket pair colorizer
reload
yay that's really cool
every to everyone who's been suggesting
that to me thank you this is this is
actually really cool when it's gonna be
super helpful so I appreciate it I'm
sorry it took me so long does anybody
ever take this survey on visual studio
code that keeps popping up it's behind
that I always say remind me later I
always want to take it but I never have
time restart to fly latest update I'll
restart after the stream ok Phoenix says
hey Jessie I made a few designs for
badges for free code camp Top
Contributor meetup would you mind taking
a look at them on here how can I share
the link Phoenix do you do you have me
on twitter you can DM me on Twitter yeah
I'm pretty sure we have each other on
Twitter DM it to me onto the link to me
on Twitter right now and I'll I'll look
it up that's actually really awesome
I have a $50 credit still for sticker
mule so I wonder if we could use any of
the designs for some some stickers Julio
says if you go to get tab and visual
studio code you can see the changes oh
no way
I never use that tab that's awesome I'm
gonna have to check that I just I never
I'm not used to having that so I'm
always like if I really wanted to see
the changes I would just do like a lucky
get div for something that's a that's
super useful learning all kind of things
today
all right so Nikki says get commit em
with so what I was saying earlier when
we were doing get messages it says it
only lets you put a title not the body
if you want to do that as well just use
git commit you'll have to deal with them
if you haven't changed the default gate
editor yet actually you're entirely
right so you don't have to put the
message in line when you're doing you
get commits you could just type git
commit it'll open up an editor for you
depending on whatever you set is your
your editor and then you can do a big
long commit message if you want I just I
never do that because it's faster to
just do a short commit message and I
almost never have to do a really long
one but that can be helpful especially
if you're doing a project where they
have like a strict structure for how to
do commit messages and they want it to
have a lot of stuff
Nino says I got a sign a new project and
react I have to build the UI from the
ground up what is your advice to start
the right way Wow see you have to do the
whole UI okay Nino if you're good with
something like Photoshop or sketch or
Adobe XD or whatever then I would do you
start with your designs like that I'm
assuming you don't have designs ready if
you already have the designs then in
business makes this a lot easier but if
you don't have the designs definitely do
it on their first get approval from
whoever you know your client or your
boss or whoever get approval of those
designs first before you start
developing it it'll save you a ton of
time you all see how I do it a lot is
that it goes back and forth with
development I mean this it's just how
things work around here
like that's I would kind of like it if
we could do design stages
get things approved but to be honest
with you it just seems like when we
start a project it we have it's not even
all thought out what people want right
so it look people talk about scope creep
when you have clients
well like working here its scope creep
is just a given like it's going to
happen because there's gonna be like
multiple people that find out the
project's happening and join in and then
now they have these ideas and so it's
it's almost not worth it to even have
these separate stages because so much is
going to change ends up being kind of a
waste of time so that's why our stuff is
kind of very fluid right and I'm working
I can't just say like hey this is the
contract you agreed to this everything
else is gonna cost more right there is
no contract like this is my my everyday
full-time job
so anyway depending on your situation
this might work differently but just to
get started do the designs first then go
in what I usually do what I like to do
that's kind of more comfortable for me
is I just take like one component I
start to build everything out in that
one component and once the component
gets big then I can start to kind of see
naturally where you should break things
out into different components like at
that point then I start breaking things
out that seems to be faster for me
sometimes if you try to think like these
are all the components I'll need
beforehand you end up wasting some some
work so anyway that's that's how I go
about it I'm not sure if it's the best
way probably not there's probably better
ways to do it but that that seems when I
can do it like that then things seem to
go like pretty well hopefully that helps
Nina Kath deesis I remember used to have
a Trello board during strange what
happened to it actually I still have a
Trello board for this what I ended up
doing is a lot of the code related stuff
now is in github as issues
and then I've been using Google keep
which is small checklists to keep myself
on track and then I've been using the
Trello board to with my student workers
to assign tasks to them so it's it's
kind of easier they don't have to get a
github account or anything like that or
figure out how to use get up they I can
show you much how I'm using the Trello
board right now actually so like this is
the kind of stuff I have a Trello now
I'm like having them do things so add
dates alright so I just had pilgrimages
information broken up so there's
separate pieces of data now so I can go
in and create a page or component for
that and then probably probably -
they'll be like a single page right so
anyway so they just go in here and we
can like talk back and forth it allows
me to attach screenshots links like so
now this one's done - so I can move this
over you see I have a backlog of things
to test - just make sure it was done
right I'm very trusting of my student
workers so anyway now like I need to add
some more cards because these ones are
pretty much finished as well so my
student worker is probably waiting for
me to give them more tasks now but
anyway that's how I'm using that so I've
just kind of separated things out like
code related stuff is strictly
everything's on github now and then
content related stuff now is on Trello
it's kind of easier with the stream so
you all don't have to have another thing
to remember to go to to check on things
like so you don't have to worry about
going to Trello like everything's in
github for all the stuff that you all
would care about which is is code stuff
and then we are also using slack so I
can also communicate with my team on
slack as well slack and we have shared
Word documents that my boss sending me
wired documents and Excel spreadsheets
with data on it too so there's quite a
variety of methods being used here
let's see Daniel says would you see my
webpage and tell me what you think yeah
sure
Daniel if you have Twitter or whatever
my link to my Twitter account is in the
description if you don't have Twitter
and you have some other social media
thing then I guess you know what you can
go to my youtube channel which is also
linked there and then I have links to
all my other social media so find me on
one of those social media things and
then direct message me because links
don't really work in here
so just message me like remind me that
you're from the stream message me and
I'll check it out and Phoenix I got your
message and so I'm checking out your
your badges right now let me bring them
over we get when you see what you all
think as well okay so here's Phoenix's
designs for the lanyards oh very nice
nice
really cool all right how about that you
know what I'm gonna copy and paste this
link and anybody who's interested in
giving some feedback on these you know
you can go to this github issue and then
you know comment here so I might have I
don't know which one I like they're
really cool but Phoenix is there anyway
cuz I'm I'm just complete rubbish when
it comes to graphic design stuff is
there any way we could take some sort of
design like this and make it into a
circular button like okay so here's like
the freaking let me switch up my screen
so you'll be able to see okay so we've
got this free code camp sticker here I
think it'd be really cool to have a
sticker like this but actually two
things would be cool one
if I de sticker like this that said live
coding with Jesse on it that would be
really fun but in regard to this if we
had some sort of sticker like this that
said something about a Top Contributor
2018 or or just talking tributary then
we could reuse it I don't know but
something like that that I can make this
sticker which this is like I think this
is a 2-inch diameter sticker I don't
know but that would be really cool and I
think I only have a week left until my
fifty dollar credit runs out so if we
can if you need get me a design that I
could use on a sticker mule I'll have
like I don't know however many stickers
I can get printed out for 50 bucks and
then I can print those out that would be
awesome so let me know because I don't I
don't really know how long that would
take you and if it would be a big deal
if it's a big deal then you know don't
worry about it but if it wouldn't take
that much work to come up with something
like that that would be really awesome
so anyway I just I would have tried to
do it myself but I like I'm not good
with that stuff let's see
michael creo says the categories should
be the faculty department then majors i
just couldn't remember the query to get
that list
categories could be Ethan says we're
still here for you
thank you Nicki says it's it's happening
what's happening
what's
Nikki what's happening I don't remember
what was happening at that part of the
stream michael says okay so this is in
regards to what cannabis well was saying
was that the name cannabis plays was
saying says well said
I remember the beat down I got when I
said the same thing when I started
watching hopefully he learns like I did
Michael I actually don't even remember
he's saying the same thing I don't doubt
that you did I just I don't know I sure
I like honestly when I first started
thinking about streaming like I assumed
everybody would have that reaction to
come in here and say like why would you
watch this guy look at that spaghetti
code like that is terrible so I'm always
just like just so surprised that people
don't say that so it happens so
infrequently I'm just not really upset
about it
when it does happen so I don't play that
like obviously I forgot when when you
said it Michael Michael says he did it
my work here is done did what
oh wait are y'all talking about when I
added the colored bracket thing
Nietzsche says anyone here use emojis in
their commit messages they're pretty
dope I never have but that that would be
really fun that sounds like something I
should do more Oh Sean says you
completed the nanodegree on react right
yes I did the Udacity react nano degree
so ocean I did do on my youtube channel
which is linked in the description I did
do a video review of that nano degree so
if you're interested in what my thoughts
are on it you can check that out but
yeah I did do that I was in the like the
first cohort so I imagine it's changed a
bit there's probably some bugs they
worked out since I've done it but so it
was like the first cohort I think was
last August I think it started so I I
guess it's been almost a year now
Nino says thank you welcome no problem
Michael says you haven't taught your
student workers how to use github that
should be the first thing you should
have taught them I know I should so when
I have interns I try to teach them a lot
more but with the student workers so
when I first talked to them when I was
kind of interviewing them I did let them
know if you're interested in learning
more coding stuff let me know like ask
me any questions we can do that and no
one really is interested so I don't know
if they're interested and they're just
like intimidated and don't want to ask
me or or they just are here to get paid
and or like I'm just gonna do well
whatever the work is and that's it which
is totally fine I mean I'm sure we've
all had jobs like that we it's like I
don't want to become a master at this
thing I just want to do my working in my
paycheck so yeah I don't know some I'm
definitely open to teaching them more
but if they're not interested then
that's one thing I definitely learned
from being a high school teacher it was
really really hard
teach someone something if they do not
want to learn yes so I kind of leave it
up to students like if they want to know
more I give them as much advice as
probably more than they want to hear but
if they're not interested then I don't I
don't push it
okay I see Daniel he's putting his sight
and here Daniel I'm opening up the sight
on my other screen and okay cool
let me pull this over actually let me
know
Daniel is it cool if I pull the your
website over on the screen so everybody
can see it or you just want me to look
at it let me know in the chat
see
okay so when everyone was excited that I
finally did something it was the black
bracket payer colorizer okay and you
realized you all were that excited about
it that I finally did it then hey john
Anson's here how's it going
no John we did not join us if we had any
exclamation for it important overrides
today we didn't we didn't have to
override anything daniel says if your
screen is 4k it may not scale well I
think the screen that everybody sees is
only 2k okay so Daniels fine with me
showing it so this will probably be the
last thing we do on the stream before I
end it I'm gonna bring over Daniels site
okay it's trying to get this at a more
reasonable ratio here okay so Daniel is
there anything in particular that you
you want me to look at with the site or
just like kind of general general stuff
and anybody in the live chat like feel
free to you know check it out as well I
guess I could let me copy and paste this
link
Oh Oh shun says is it my connection or
Jessie's webcam oh no what's uh what's
happening let me know something's up
with the stream it looks okay on my end
but maybe maybe something's happening I
don't I don't see it
let's see daniel-san change pages all
right John says no one great hope your
day is great - yes it's not bad not bad
so far
okay you see the next G query that's
cool Daniel what are you using for the
for this let's see what happened you
have some sort of plugin for like this
layout or is this all just like kind of
custom-made
I mean so I meant translate this if you
don't mind chapter it approaches opening
crashing interesting
okay
okay cool CSS grid awesome daniel says
put sombreros in the search some be
sombreros that's pretty cool
okay so no framework just shake we're
put seda in the search
cool let me see sowhat's
so HT chapters
it's the the site's really fast like the
search just immediately pops up
John says Nikki has got me running on
the edge of Gatsby beta-version to
learning a lot getting many hints from
Nikki's blog awesome
he says click some maybe click something
on you ok cool
it's really cool I mean I I would just
say like styling was there's just some
some stuff that needs so like there's
some overlap stuff going on right here
here so I mean the the little details
it's it like yeah so I would maybe make
sure that the the areas of overlap
aren't aren't happening but in terms of
functionality and speed its it's very
impressive
Nikki says how do you translate the
toggle translate on a page if it doesn't
just show up up and in this corner
there's like this little translate page
icon so I just click on that if that
doesn't show up I'm not sure how but
that's right I just I click there
okay
all right I think we're gonna wrap
things up now
so anyway yeah Daniel if if you have any
more questions or anything else you want
me to look at for there like I said find
me on social media or and that goes for
anybody if anybody wants to ask me a
question or anything check out my
youtube channel and all my social media
stuff is linked from there and um you
know my DMS are open everywhere I will
I'm not gonna stream tomorrow so I'm
gonna have surgery on my wrist tomorrow
and so I'll definitely not stream
tomorrow I don't know how long my
recovery is gonna be and if I'm gonna be
able to type so it may hopefully I can
stream next week but if I can't stream
next week then that's probably why so
probably probably see y'all sometime
next week then I don't think there's
anything else I need to say yeah so
anyway I thought it was pretty good
stream today we got done you know a lot
of what we wanted to get done not not
too many airs or anything like that so I
had a good time thank you for all your
help and suggestions and finally getting
me to install the bracket pair colorizer
so I'll see you all next week and until
then have a have a great rest of the
week in a great weekend